hi guys it has been a wonderful
Christmas but now I've gotta get back to
business and I've got to play some more
horror game this game's called NOx
timore not too sure how you say it but
it's supposed to be very scary and it's
just like a maze game with things
jumping on you and I hate this game so
enjoy why are there like little bumps on
the floor they supposed to be rocks cuz
they do not look like rocks I'm sorry
can I open this can I open the drawers
why not can I interact with anything
nope why is it just a random chess with
- OH
knives why can you never take any kind
of weapon in these sorts of games it
makes no sense to me
fine whatever okay whatever
oh I hate the squeaky doors okay hey how
the flashlights are always so terrible
and these sorts of games as well I know
why but still hmm dad for some reason I
don't know why would that my eyes you
saw the fingers wasn't here nothing
cannot open it okay where do I go now
where do I go now what oh hey what are
you you're weird
mm-hmm Oh
don't follow me hmm oh no okay cuz it up
thank you but I don't know what I'm
supposed to do though like there's just
those two rooms and that freaky thing
and he's out there in the corridor now
and I can't go back out there because
he's gonna be waiting oh my god
why is he still that he can't walk
through doors Kenny oh gee I don't know
what's to gonna use his knife to kill
him please pick up the knife I just
wanna pick up the knife get any of these
things do he's gone [ __ ] why it's gone
this is weirdly unnerving
look there's no creepy music or anything
and I don't know why I can't open any of
these things and it's just the tea's
having the knives on the wall I can't
even pick them up right hi can you tell
me where I'm supposed to go please
please cuz I don't know what I'm
supposed to do here it looks like you're
the only thing that's gonna help you
probably not just gonna kill me instead
okay so guys oh oh look I'm glad to see
you here why did I walk toward you when
I saw that was ridiculous there was no
noise oh it was no sound or anything why
did I just scream you uh you can turn
your head 360 360 degrees is disgusting
you know that I don't like you can you
please go away from me
bring your back I'm going back
is there another note here oh wow wait
this is different this is new never I
can't
oh okay noises are happening now I'm
already screaming out the noise I can
feel I quit the noise I didn't tear
about these I'm so far but it comes to
jump scares
I'm the worst okay okay well I'm just
gonna again he's gonna be behind me
again yeah I knew wait wait what oh my
god there's oh my god that's like nice
of you guys why are you here white until
you want me what do you want me for [ __ ]
he's gone he was just there they had she
gives me goose bumps that's really like
oh my god it's a really simple concept
it's so creepy
please go away I don't want to be with
you guys okay it's another one what's
this thing I can escape thanks
how wait I need Pizza turnarounds
there's no this jump scare No Oh guys
gave me any Dora
thanks guys is so creepy
thank you oh okay I'll go around you
open up at your door oh they turn off
the lights they know how much I love the
darkness know what what I'm back in the
same room as before
oh I just roll in me they're just dronin
me fine
oh oh oh oh it's his but but but we
don't like you don't see anything
hello what's the but whoa what was that
noise it was like did someone fart they
farted but but what is the but there's
the but what the hell is that cuz that's
not one of that what was that supposed
to Adam because nothing happened and
then you'll come back anyway no I won't
if you let me escape I I promise you I
won't come back I'll happily leave and
go on my merry way back to where I came
from where did I even come from and how
did I get here those are the questions I
always ask and they never get answered
that's another another one of those
noises are they in the pipes they're in
the pipes oh this way
okay you have you have no other choice
oh oh I see how it is Hey
what any one was that feels like a
bloody football other thing it's good
yeah it's getting confusing now okay
what was it is that eyes look can you
see its eyes someone's watching me
creepy I'm watching them to be fair
maybe they're scared as well oh gosh
do dark in here I can't see anything
oh it's a bookshelf where's my
flashlight gone there's the eyes let's
go and see who's watching us they go we
got peeping tom that's always rude don't
look at me Tom where's he gone he's just
gone okay okay you what is it father I
don't know oh you can't get away from me
what if I wonder though [ __ ] I can't see
anything
oh bloody hell what the hell was that oh
it's just a book being done he's good
okay then I was so weird yeah just have
a book throw books at me literature
oh-oh-oh what does it say I am part of
you what part which part
the bad part the dark part the toilets
oh I just walked through the toilet door
yeah that's how it works okay
these toilets are pretty big nothing in
the toilet that's surprising usually
taught it's already creepy okay
whatever anything down around here oh
okay there's more toilets oh yeah I've
got two keys now what do I do with these
things though I know there must be no
it's gotta be something in one of these
toilets that's gonna freak me out this
one okay hey you gotta show me where to
go I missed you I missed you so much I
missed you hmm
this is my world okay well can I go back
to mine please I don't like your world
can I pick up my pleasure
yeah okay it's your world is it I see
how it is I did you don't move oh my god
this two of you Mooji your way
don't like that one
what's this noises now no one voices
what is this
am I on an alien planet or something no
I have no idea okay I'm just walking
an endless corridor that's probably
gonna end in one massive John scare oh
look left or right left
Oh or down in the spotlight right oh why
why are they banging I don't like the
banging oh oh look us please move it and
every night
yes what happened what happens at night
time let me through
fine
what happens in the night time tell me
shadows
what the hell where's my light go on oh
it's still there it's really bad okay oh
not the other side it's being far too
kind to me this game something's gonna
happen soon
I can see something okay you're gonna
tell me what happens every night you're
trapped in it oh well I could have
probably guessed that pick it up
flashlights people in the flashlights
people so I'm guessing all those weird
things I'm saying they were people
originally and then they got turned into
whatever those things are what excuse me
what does happen okay I'm glad to see
you here again you can escape but you'll
come back anyway you have no other
choice you can't get away from me I am
polity this is my world you live in and
every night you're trapped in it night
marisol disorder also known as dream
anxiety disorder is a sleep disorder
characterized by frequent nightmares a
person experiencing nightmare disorder
would have trouble growing through
everyday tasks the anxiety and life of
sleep caused by fearful dreams would
hinder the individual from completing
everyday jobs efficiently and correctly
oh so it has a meaning to it as well
it's a pretty cool idea for a game I'd
love to see another one and maybe have
some sort of health thing in there to
make it harder and you can actually die
in sleep because they do say that when
you die you know
you join your life so that'll be quick
let me know what you thought of this
game and give it a thumbs up if you
enjoy have a video you think by oh no no
oh you're the woman
no can I move please I got